deux cent cinquante sept ans après la
fondation de la ville montréal retrouve
le nom et le coeur de son enfance la
place ville marie
[Musique]
cependant depuis 20 ans toronto tentait
de ravir à montréal son titre de
métropole pour le moment la course est
terminée
déclare le grand journaliste du taux
lenteur des risques à pierre burton
montréal a gagné la partie place
ville-marie donne à montréal une avance
de dix années
[Musique]
ce complexe architectural de 55 étages
fut construit au coût de 80 millions sur
un site d'une superficie de cet art
d'un poids total de 150 mille tonnes et
construit par plus de 9000 hommes de
tous métiers qui on gagne un salaire
total de 24 millions six cent mille
dollars
ce complexe se créer un pôle magnétique
au coeur de montréal
paris à la tour eiffel florence le dôme
de ruiner les skis venise la place
saint-marc new york la forêt de gratte
ciels et montréal à sa place ville marie
[Musique]
au point où nous sommes en ce moment
c'est à dire à 70 pieds au dessus du
niveau de la mer soit cinq étages plus
bas que le niveau du boulevard
dorchester s'étend la gare centrale des
chemins de fer nationaux par où les
résidents de la banlieue arrive à
montréal ou retournent chez eux à ce
même niveau à l'est des rails les
colonnes de soutènement retiennent au
dessus de nos têtes
59 min 488 tonnes de structures d'acier
16 millions de livres d'acier d'armature
146 mille verges public de beto 2
millions 600 mille livres d'aluminium
bref la place ville marie et le plus
haut édifice du corbeau noir d'un poids
total de 300 millions de livres
[Musique]
les urbanistes ont prévu qu'à ce niveau
seront aménagés les facilités d'accès à
une station de métro aux déçus du niveau
des rails deux étages sont aménagés en
terrain de stationnement
l'urbaniste qui réservent quatre acres
de terrain précieux au coeur d'une
grande ville pour une esplanade eux
destinés aux passants accompli un fait
sans précédent
voilà une des contributions les plus
significatives de place ville marie à la
cité de montréal du centre date la za le
passant découvre à l'ouest l'immeuble
sun life au sud la cathédrale
marie-reine-du-monde l'hôtel reine
elizabeth
et l'immeuble de la compagnie si arles
à l'est l'édifice cruciforme de la
banque royale du canada
[Musique]
au nord il découvre la rue mais quel
collège qui conduit à l'entrée des
garages souterrains rue cathcart
[Musique]
au niveau de la rue cathcart sous
l'immeuble de lembeye et l'ol des
arcades et claires des boutiques
[Musique]
au niveau de la plaza l'immeuble de
l'inpl quand les formes une arcade
qu'une galerie couverte réservé aux
institutions et aux étalages
[Musique]
sur cette oasis en bordure de la rue
mansfield des jets d'eau alimenteront un
large bassin que deux plates bandes de
pain autrichien encadre tous les piétons
doivent gravir quelques marches pour
atteindre le niveau de l'esclave
[Musique]
17 lampadaires ou cachés parisien ed a
décoré et a illuminé la plaza disposés
près des quatre courts d'escalier qui
conduisent à l'imposante galerie
marchande
il est clair les quatre murs de ces
cours encadrés de sièges en bordure
parapet
[Musique]
les cours des limites le centre de
l'esplanade de réserver aux activités
tenues sur la plaza
[Musique]
cette scène peut confortablement
accommoder 1500 personnes et des
facilités de son et lumière ont été
aménagés pour la réalisation de diverses
manifestations
[Musique]